foreign
[Music]
eternity
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
field of in North Carolina in September
another beautiful Harvest day here in
Hampton Farms Canon country we're gonna
catch a tractor as it comes by and then
I'm going to step in behind it these are
Virginia type peanuts that we grow
Hampton farms for in shells the best the
best in shell peanuts around had a great
growing season this year so uh let's
watch the tractor come by
foreign
as you can see these peanuts grow under
the ground
and what our farmer is doing right now
is what's called a peanut Digger and
they dig them up out of the ground and
it inverts them throws them up to the
sunlight for two or three days where
they do some field drying and in about
72 hours it'll probably be in here with
the peanut combine and pick the pick the
pods off the vines and put into a drying
trailer so this is
absolutely a beautiful crop here